so today we are going to go through some
of the different testimonies that were
given not only yesterday but today in
the Trump impeachment inquiry and they
are devastating particularly Gordon
sunland's today but this is a good time
to just sort of be very real now that we
are what like twenty five hours into the
public testimony of this thing and just
all be on the same page that if
Democrats can't make something happen if
they can't get something from these
hearings it's going to be extremely
embarrassing and it may backfire
significantly and what I mean by that is
the molar probe happened behind closed
doors there were almost no leaks
it happened in private we went about our
lives during the Muller probe and then
we heard it was over and we got the bar
propaganda letter which we immediately
knew was merely a propaganda letter and
then the report came out and then Mulder
testified and then people could debate
okay what do we get from it what don't
we get from it but it was not an
excruciating process into which so much
network TV time has been invested we
have roughly twenty five as of this as
of right now I think we're about 25
hours in to the public hearings more
today we had nearly 12 hours yesterday
we've got another four to six hours
tomorrow people are watching the ratings
are actually good despite what Devon
Nunez likes to say oh the ratings are
down people are part of paying attention
to this stuff even though it is at the
same time boring in a sense even though
it's extraordinarily important but it is
monopolizing news television for the
greater part of every day and then after
it's over the news shows are mostly
analyzing what it is that took place the
substance of it is damning to trump in a
way that words almost can't encompass
and we'll talk about that next including
about Gordon sunland's testimony clearly
many people understood what was going on
was a trade a quid pro quo an attempt at
bribery and extorted act but is anything
going to happen in terms of impeachment
itself 62% of Trumpets say they will
never turn on Trump if Trump is don't
turn on Trump republican senators won't
turn on Trump
then the question of Dems getting
something becomes can the hearings plus
whatever commentary Democrats can add
actually shocked people enough about
Donald Trump's brazen actions that it
swings public opinion against him and
pushes him out of office via losing
re-election in 2020 I don't know the
answer to that on the one hand half the
country now wants Trump removed as I
told you yesterday based on new polling
on the other hand this is a lot of eggs
in the basket of public hearings and for
a whole suite of reasons I don't know
that it's going to go anywhere if it
doesn't I fear there will be a rebound
effect and it could be very embarrassing
for Democrats again not because the
facts don't support impeachment with
Gordon sunland's testimony today I don't
know how anyone could argue that this
was not an extorted bribery quid pro quo
but the problem is it's not that the
hearings are a waste of time they're
actually the opposite they are so
important and that's why we've been
covering all of them on the david pakman
show YouTube channel live it's been long
days here at the David Pakman show but
because they will be needlessly
ridiculed if they don't get something
out of it for having taken over news
television for endless hour after hour
after hour week after week after week
and getting quote nothing remember it's
quote nothing it could end up having the
rebound effect of helping Donald Trump
secure re-election I don't want that to
happen I fear that it will if we don't
all make sure that these hearings are
seen for what they are which is
extraordinarily damning assessments of
what Donald Trump and the people around
him have done let's now get to yesterday
in today's hearings when I was a kid
breakfast cereal was like my secret
weapon for starting the day and then I
grew up and I realized it's full of
sugar it's loaded with carbs this
episode is sponsored by magic spoon
which is a new cereal company that has
figured out a way to recreate your
favorite childhood cereals with zero
sugar twelve grams of protein and just
three grams of neck car
per serving magic spoon has four flavors
based on the classics cocoa cinnamon
frosted and fruity plus a variety pack
that lets you try them all they've
recreated the taste and texture of
classic sugary cereal but it tastes so
good you would not guess it is not one
of those sugary cereals it's keto
friendly gluten-free grain free soy free
low carb and GMO free my favorite is
cocoa I must admit
go to magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman
to grab a variety pack and try it today
use our promo code Pakman at checkout to
get free shipping and Magic spoon is so
confident in their product it comes with
a 100% happiness guarantee so if for any
reason you don't like it they'll refund
your money no questions asked go to
magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman and use
the code PA k ma n Pakman to get free
shipping